[Music]
in a recent interview with swift
vitamins and supply company
chris hemsworth confirmed what many had
already suspected
the shooting of thor love and thunder
will start in january
this was not entirely the team's wish
but the current situation did not allow
an alternative
the filming will take place in far away
australia where hamsworth as thor
and tessa thompson's valkyrie will stand
in front of the camera
natalie portman is hammer swinging jane
foster aka
mighty thor and christian bale has not
yet further defined villain will also be
part of the team
behind the camera taika vitia's director
is responsible for their creative
realization
while kaiten robinson is in charge of
the script the current release date is
february 11
2022. after a recent report by deadline
and the already more or less concrete
statement by vin diesel in february
it is now very likely that the fast and
furious saga will finally end with part
10 and part 11.
so after the release of part 9 in may
next year fans can look forward to a
probably
spectacular double finale with dominic
toretto and co
if you believe deadline the right man
for the direction is already on the
starting blocks named tokyo drift
director justin lin
doesn't seem that unlikely because lin
has worked on four films of the series
so far
and is therefore largely responsible for
the gigantic success
although there is no reliable
information on the story of the double
finale yet
it seems very likely that most of the
traditional cast around
michelle rodriguez jodanna brewster
nathalie emmanuel
sun kang and ko will be back in the game
but before that happens
fast and furious 9 adds a chapter to the
story before it leads into the grand
finale
wwe superstar john cena will appear in
the next part as torato's enemy brother
jacob
and possibly have a few more conflicts
with them
so you can look forward to may 28 2021
when fast and furious 9 will probably be
released
unfortunately there is no information
about a potential release of parts 10
and 11 at the moment
by the way there are rumors that tom
holland is currently in talks with vin
diesel for an appearance in the double
finale of fast and furious 10 and 11.
what would you think about a spider-man
appearance in the franchise
write it down in the comments almost 11
years after the release of the 3d
spectacle
avatar the successor is shot and post
production is in full
swing this week we could see a surprise
on the official twitter channel of
avatar
because it seems that eddie falco will
embody general art moore
the commander of the military
organization rda
of course many fans now ask themselves
if this could be a hint for a new bad
guy role in the avatar universe
after all the rda is not exactly known
for its diplomatic skills with the navi
but rather for the exploitation of
important resources
it seems that general ardmore will
follow in the footsteps of his
unscrupulous predecessor colonel miles
quarage and continue his work
not only in avatar 2 but also in the
successors as it seems
the story will focus on the family life
of the young parents
jake and nathiri who have to fight the
bitter battle with the rda on the one
hand
and on the other hand will show the
wonderful underwater role of pandora in
all its glory for the first time
the release date of avatar 2 is
currently set for december 2022
since the initial announcement of the
new dc blockbuster static shock at the
fandom
in august there has been a lot of
movement behind the scenes
as the hollywood reporter reports
exclusively black panther star michael b
jordan will now join the production team
however there's no talk of an acting
performance or similar at the moment
the original comic static shock made its
debut in 1993 and is published by
milestone comics which has worked
closely with dc in the past
at the center of the plot is young
virgil hawkins a teenager who has had
electromagnetic superpowers since
contact with an unknown gas
unfortunately no exact release date is
known
at the moment since its release in 2017
justice league has had a hard time
convincing its fans
so it was all the more gratifying to
hear in may that original director zack
snyder
after retiring for personal reasons
would release his own cut version
the so-called snyder [ __ ] will be
released next year as of miniseries
and later as a four hour film it's
logical that there will be no lack of
new scenes to shoot and so jared leto
will once again slip into the role of
the joker
quite interesting after all leto was
never originally planned
also dark side the villain of the piece
who is missing in the movie version
will now appear in schneider count for
the very first time
a much bigger role will be given to ben
affleck as batman ray fisher
cyborg and amber heard as mera through
several retakes
you can look also forward to new music
because the dutch junkie xl who also
composed for mad max fury road
will contribute some tracks so far the
release of sex schneider's justice
league
is planned for the first half of 2021 on
the streaming service
hbo max fans may even be able to see
another dc spectacle in the cinema this
year
namely wonder woman 1984 after a total
of six postponements however
many are not sure whether the cinema
date for the screen adventure on
december 25th
2020 can be kept director patty jenkins
is skeptical to say the least
as no one can be sure what the situation
will be like in a few weeks
according to a report by variety the
cinema business in the usa
could recover at least for a short time
during cinema openings in the state of
new york
which is important for the film world
which in turn could be an incentive for
warner
to release the film this year
[Music]
you